mit dieser computersimulation wurde
jetzt tatsächlich ein geheimnis unserer
heimatgalaxie der milchstraße gelüftet
zum ersten mal haben forscher der den
kosmos nicht nur sehr detailreich
sondern auch in sehr großem maßstab
simuliert und die ergebnisse sind zum
teil wirklich verblüffend denn auch
unerwartete effekte wurden beobachtet
die so nicht programmiert wurden hammer
kriegs um science-fiction hier gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen kosmologische simulationen am
computer sind nichts neues doch
astronomie teams hatten bislang mit
einem echten dilemma zu tun denn die
rechenleistung ist selbst bei
supercomputern begrenzt und erfordert
somit eine entscheidung die simulation
kann entweder sehr detailgenau sein oder
aber ein großes volumen umfassen dabei
ist beides extrem wichtig denn nur dann
sind nicht nur statistische rückschlüsse
möglich sondern auch die erklärung
wichtige eigenschaften auf kleinen
skalen so war die vorhersagekraft der
bisherigen simulationen immer auf
irgendeine art und weise eingeschränkt
forschungsteams aus den usa und
deutschland haben jetzt erstmalig eine
simulation entwickelt die beides kann an
der entwicklung der sogenannten tnf die
simulation war auch das max planck
institut für astronomie in heidelberg
beteiligt dazu heißt es auf der webseite
in einem simulierten würfelförmigen
ausschnittes weltalls mit seitenlangen
von 230 millionen lichtjahren kann tmg
50 physikalische phänomene darstellen
die auf einer million mal kleineren
skalen auftreten und so die
gleichzeitige entwicklung tausender von
galaxien über 13,8 milliarden jahre
kosmische geschichte hinweg verfolgen
die bausteine der simulation sind dabei
20 milliarden teilchen die dunkle
materie sterne kosmisches gas
magnetfelder und supermassereiche
schwarze löcher darstellen
das ist also echt nicht ohne und tnt
fifty ist mit recht die bisher
detailreichsten kosmologische groß
simulation doch um diese leistung zu
erbringen haben 16.000 prozessorkerne
kurs auf dem supercomputer hazel henn in
stuttgart tatsächlich mehr als ein jahr
lang rund um die uhr gerechnet
um das noch einmal anders zu
verdeutlichen auf einem einzigen prozess
wäre damit eine rechenzeit von 15.000
jahren not
ähnlich gewesen doch das ganze hat sich
gelohnt beispielsweise hat die
simulation die entwicklung unserer
milchstraße endlich enträtselt das große
geheimnis über das sich fachleute
weltweit den kopf zerbrachen hängt mit
der dünnen scheiben vom solcher
spiralgalaxien zusammen hier
konzentrieren sich gas und sterne
wann und wie hat sich diese scheiben
form gebildet und gab es das auch schon
bei früheren galaxien mithilfe der neu
entwickelten groß simulationen fanden
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler heraus dass diese form
der galaxien hauptsächlich durch die
stern bildung bestimmt wird bei der
entstehung neuer sterne schwenken diese
auf kreisbahnen um den kern der galaxie
ein sie bringen quasi ordnung in das
ganze und zwar durch ihre kreisbewegung
dadurch kommen chaotische gasströme zur
ruhe
die sich dann schließlich auch diesem
galaktischen karussell anschließen dazu
die astronomen anna-lisa pilic die an
der studie beteiligt war
tmg fifty zeigt dass sich unsere eigenen
milchstraße galaxie mit ihrer dünnen
scheibe voll im trend wird findet das
nur ein paar milliarden jahre alte
universum war viel chaotischer als heute
und die tmg fünf die simulation
offenbarte noch ein weiteres super
spannendes phänomen das die fachleute so
nicht erwartet hatten
wenn gaswolken durch supernova und
ausbrüchen von schwarzen löchern aus
galaxien herausgeschleudert werden
herrscht anfangs chaos doch auch hier
kommt nach und nach ordnung rein
die gasströme ordnen sich zu einer
struktur die zwei eistüten ähnelt beide
spitzen berühren sich die galaxie dabei
in der mitte
doch das ganze hatte das forschungsteam
vorab nicht ein programm mit dass bei
einer simulation solcher nicht
kalkuliert das ergebnis herauskommt ist
ein großer erfolg dazu dylan nelson vom
max planck institut für astrophysik in
garching diese phänomene ergeben sich
auf natürliche weise aus dem
zusammenspiel der grundlegenden
physikalischen bestandteile unseres
modell universums numerische experimente
dieser art sind besonders erfolgreich
wenn mehr herauskommt als man hinein
gesteckt hat und die forschenden sind
optimistisch denn die auswertungen der
tmg fünf die simulation hat gerade erst
begonnen und auch für andere expertinnen
und experten sollen die daten zugänglich
gemacht werden somit wird die chance
dass noch weitere kosmische phänomene
aufgespürt werden können noch größer als
sie eh schon sehr
wahnsinn ist das universum eine
simulation das fragt der ziemlich coole
kanal asto comics tv also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
alles andere ist nicht gut fürs karma
also bis dahin bleibt dran